من المعروف ان الشلالا ينجم عن توقف وصول
الاوامر العصبيه من الدماغ الى الاطراف
وفي اليابان طور العلماء مستشعرات
الكترونيه لقراءه تلك الاوامر في الدماغ
ونقلها مباشره الى الاطراف
متجاوزه نقطه انقطاع الحبل الشوكي كما هو
الحال في هذه البدله الروبوتيه
لكن استعاده المصابين بالشلل لقدرتهم على
الحركه ربما يكون ابسط من ذلك بكثير
فهذا الكرسي المتحرك المزود بدواسات يعيد
الحركه للساقين امرا وصفه بعض مستخدمه
بالسحر
ولكنه السر يكمن في منعكس عصبي يعرف
بمنعكس المشي وهو لا يحتاج لاوامر عصبيه
من الدماء
تحريك رجليه كانه يمشي ويعرف ذلك بانعكس
المشي وهو لا يحتاج الى اوامر من الدماغ
ونفس المنعكس يجعل المشتولين سيقانهم
في ساق واحده ان تخلق رد فعل انعكاسيا
ليتحرك الطرف المقابل المشلول
الكرسي نحو 20 عاما من التجارب للتعرف على
زاويه الافضل بين الساق والجذع التي تنقذ
منعكس المشي في النخاع الشوكي
محركي على التنقل فقط وبعض من يعانون من
الاعاقه الحركيه يستخدمونه ايضا لتعلم
الرقص في هذا المركز التابعي للبلديه قرب
طوكيو يتدرب شخصان مصابان بالشلل على اداء
الراقص على انغام الموسيقى ايه اصيبت
بنزيف دماغيا سبب لها شلل نصفيا
[موسيقى]
استطيع ان اتنقل بسهوله وتنزها بنفسي
واركب القطار
قبل 2500 عام وحتى الان كانت تحريكه
مقتصرا على اداره عجلته باليدين او
بمحركين كهربائي ولكن ها هو الكرسي الجديد
يكسر حدود الاعاقه ويعيد تعريف قدره
المصابين بالشلل على الحركه هذه سلامه
الجزيره طوكيو